17 novembre 2018 à dijon le coup d'essai
est un coup de maître 6000 gilet jaune
sont dans la rue même si cela ne se
passe pas exactement comme l'avait prévu
les organisateurs de cette journée
censée partir sur la rocade et en
l'occurrence les manifestants décidés de
faire autrement et de manifester
apparemment en ville parmi les gilet
jaune qui avait initié ce premier
rassemblement dijonnais certains ont
aujourd'hui pris leurs distances avec le
mouvement
contactés ils n'ont pas souhaité en dire
plus expliquant qu'ils avaient tout
simplement passer le relais d'autres
sont toujours là gérald gourdon par
exemple nous l'avons retrouvé
aujourd'hui sur un rond-point à tonnerre
début j'étais un peu dubitatif je
pensais que ça allait durer grosso modo
deux semaines de trois semaines et enfin
il contient beaucoup de solidarité en
france et on peut voir que les gilet
jaune sont sont unis voici le qg de ces
gilet jaune tonnerrois l'auberge de la
matrone chassé d'un premier rang
pointent ils l'ont rebaptisé sur un
terrain privé où il envisage même de
faire un potager dans quelques semaines
comme partout ils sont là à cause des
salaires ou des retraites trop mince
pour joindre les deux bouts mais ils
sont là aussi parce qu'ils vivent
quelque chose qu'il n'aurait pas imaginé
un jour un samedi mon mari me dit que
pas venir avec moi au gilet là-bas au
carrefour d'auchan il me dit pour une
heure j'ai dit oui ok mais quand il
était l'heure de partir en dit qu'est ce
que tu fais tu restes ou on s'en va on
en reste niveau politique je pense que
bill vont rester sur la même longueur
d'onde a carrément clairement on voit
les débats qui nous enfume on voit on
voit on voit que sa part ça part
vraiment dans tous les sens et mais je
pense que les gens ils veulent pas que
ça s'arrête donc pour pas que ça
s'arrête
eh ben
info continue la mobilisation faut
trouver de nouvelles idées
par exemple convaincre les maires des
petites communes étranglés par la baisse
des dotations de les rejoindre
voilà une des pistes entendu aujourd'hui
pas très portés sur les grosses manifs
les gilets jaunes des ronds-points
veulent essayer d'agir là où ils sont